Transcriber: Omar El Roby
المدقّق: Mujtaba bakhet
(تصفيق)
أهلاً وسهلاً. كيف الأحوال؟
في البداية..
أود أن أطرح عليكم بعض الأسئلة.
وأرجو أن يكون الرد برفع يدكم.
أولاً..
مَن منكم خسر مباراة من قبل؟
حسناً.
مَن منكم خسر مباراة في لعبة “فيفا” مثلاً؟
دائمًا ما تشعرون
أنه فقط كان ينقصكم هدفًا وحيداً على الفوز.
إنه إحساس صعبٌ للغاية.
حسناً.
دعونا نتعمق في الأمر قليلاً.
مَن منكم فقد شخصًا؟
سواء قد أنهى علاقته به،
أو توقف عن الحديث معه
أو لا قدر الله قد وافته المنية.
كما نرى في هذه الشريحة،
“لقد عانى معدل 98 بالمائة
من نوع ما من الخسارة”.
ماذا يعني ذلك؟
يعني أننا نعرّف معنى “الخسارة” بشكل مختلف.
سواء أكانت خسارة فرض من العائلة،
خسارة صديق، هزيمة في فعالية رياضية،
أو خسارة حيوان أليف.
كلنا بشر.
كلنا مختلفون.
حسنًا، دعوني أروي عليكم قصة.
كنت أعرف صديقًا،
كان في الصف السادس الابتدائي.
كان صبيًا جميلًا،
ولديه أم وأب يحبونه جدًا.
للأسف والده كان دائمًا ما يصاب بالأمراض.
وكان يتردد إلى المستشفى في فترةٍ ما،
ويخرج منها.
كان دائمًا ما يذهب إليها ويخرج منها.
موال! (أي أمر كبير للغاية)
أنهى دراسته الإبتدائية ثم سافر.
من حقه أن يكون سعيدًا!
وبمرور أقل من أربعة وعشرين ساعة
أجرت جدته مكالمة هاتفية مع والدته.
الجدة: “مرحبًا!”
“نعم يا حبيبتي.. ماذا؟!”
“حسنًا، حسنًا، إلى اللقاء.”
ذهبت الجدة إلى الفتى وأخبرته
بأن يحضّر أمتعته بسرعة وبدون نقاش.
لم يفهم الفتى ما الذي قد حل!
عاد الفتى وهو يفكر في العديد من الأمور،
ولا يستطيع أن يدرك ما الذي قد حل.
عاد الفتى فنام، ثم استيقظ.
وجد أمامه والدته تنهال منها الدموع.
فسألها: “ما الذي حدث؟”
فأجابته والدته: “لقد توفى والدك!”
فرد: “ماذا؟!”
اتضح بأن الأب كان مصابًا بسرطان الكبد.
“سرطان القولون والمستقيم”
أمر نهائي!
دعونا نتحدث قليلًا عن هذا الفتى
دعونا نتعرف كيف تعامل مع الفقدان
من خلال أربع أدوات مهمة.
وتسمى الأداة الأولى (الشعور بكل شئ)
ماذا تعني؟
فإذا صادفت أمرًا سعيدًا فتسعد،
وإذا واجهت أمرًا عصيبُا فتحزن.
لا تنكر أي شعور تشعر به!
دعوني أضرب لكم مثالًا
أنا أحمل بيدي كوبًا من الماء
فقمت بصب الماء فيه حتى امتلئ عن أخره.
ماذا سيحدث إذا قمت بصب المزيد؟
سينسكب الماء.
سيحدث ما يسمى “تعبئة زائدة“.
دعوني أضرب لكم مثالًا يتعلق بنا كبشر.
فبداخلنا ما يسمى “زجاجة المشاعر”
ينطبق الأمر نفسه مع زجاجة المياه.
فعلى سبيل المثال،
واجهتُ أمرًا محزنًا، فأخزنه.
وواجهت أمرًا مُغضِبًا، فأخزنه.
وأظل أخزن حتى يصل الأمر إلى منتهاه.
ثم أواجه موقفًا بسيطًا جدًا من شأنه إغضابي
فيحدث انهيار، صياح وصراخ
“انهيار عصبي”
وهذه هي فائدة إفراغ “زجاجة المشاعر“.
علينا دائمًا بأن نخرج كل ما يصيبنا بالغضب.
لا ينبغي بأن نخزن بداخلنا.
والأداة الثانية هي (التعبير عن نفسك)
عليك بأن تحاول إيجاد من تثق فيه،
وتتحدث معه بكل أريحية.
سواء أكان فردًا من العائلة،
أو صديقًا مقربًا.
عندما تتحدث باستمرار مع هذا الشخص
فستجد نفسك قادرًا على قول
كل ما يدور بذهنك، سواء أكان متعلقًا بيومك
أو برحلة جميلة
أو بذهابك إلى حفل ما.
أو تتحدث عن الخسارة التي تعرضت لها.
وهكذا!
ستجد بأنك لست قادرًا على التحدث
مع القريبين فقط، بل مع أي شخص في أي مكان.
بكل سهولة!
تسمى الأداة الثالثة (كن مبدعًا!)
فإذا شعرت أنك غير قادر على التعبير عن ذاتك
من الممكن بأن تختار الإبداع،
فهو “مخرج بديل“.
يمكنك رسم ما تشعر به، أو تغنيه في أغنية،
أو تتجه لكتابة الشِعر.
يمكنك فعل أي شئ كي تعبر عن مشاعرك،
وتراها واضحة أمامك.
سواء أكانت مدونة على ورقة عادية،
أو على ورق المفكرة، أو أي شئ آخر.
بهذا الشكل يمكننا تلخيص الأدوات الثلاث
في ثلاث كلمات مفتاحية رئيسية .
الشعور، التعبير والإبداع.
تسمى الأداة الرابعة (كن على دراية بنفسك!)
ما هو الوعي الذاتي في الأساس؟
الوعي الذاتي هو إدراكك التام بمشاعرك.
-أتعني “صادفت أمرًا سعيدًا فأسعد، صحيح؟”
-لا ليس الأمر كذلك.
“كونك مدركًا لذاتك يعني أنك قادر على
معالجة كل أنواع المشاعر داخليًا وخارجيًا.”
فباستطاعتك التحكم في مشاعرك وقتما تشاء،
سواء أكنت تريد إظهارها أو تخزينها.
هناك طرق كثيرة يمكن أن يكون
الشخص من خلالها مدركًا لذاته.
فمثلا يمكنك شراء مذكرة يوميات
فتدون مثلاً: “لقد صنعت أمي لي
اليوم طعامًا أحبه للغاية.”
“فأنا سعيد”
“قال لي صديقي اليوم كلمة سيئة للغاية”
“فصرت غاضبًا”
عندما يدون الشخص كل هذه الأمور
سيستطيع تمييز الأشياء التي تسعده
عن الأشياء التي تحزنه.
ستتمكن من استيعاب مشاعرك
كما ذكرت، ستتمكن من تمييز
الأشياء الجيدة عن الأشياء السيئة.
حسنًا.
أود أن أطرح عليكم بعض الأسئلة.
وسيكون الرد أيضًا برفع يدكم.
أولًا، “مَن منكم يعتقد بأنه يستطيع
التعامل مع الخسارة؟”
حسنًا.
“مَن منكم سيمنح نفسه تقييمًا عاليًا من أصل
خمسة بإنه يمكنه تحقيق الوعي الذاتي؟”
حسنًا.
“مَن منكم يعتقد بأن هذه الأدوات
ستقدم يد العون لهم؟”
كما نرى، قال البعض: “نعم“،
وقال البعض الآخر: “لا“.
أهذا أمر خاطئ؟ بالطبع لا!
دعوني أضرب لكم مثالًا أخر،
فأنا أعشق الأمثلة.
مَن منكم يحب عصير البرتقال؟
أنا لا أحبه!
ما رأيكم؟
إنه لا يروقني.
أهذا يعني أنكم على خطأ؟
أهذا يعني أنني على خطأ؟
لا!
فنحن بشر ومختلفون.
كلنا لدينا أذواق مختلفة.
وكذلك الأمر في الأدوات.
فلا يعني أن هذه الأدوات كما أفادت
شخصًا ما بأنها ستفيدك.
فمن الممكن أن تذهب إلى معالج نفسي.
دائمًا هناك  مخرج!
حسنًا، لقد قلت لكم بأن هذا الفتى
فعل هذا وذاك واستخدم أدواتًا.
فمن هذا الفتى من الأساس؟
هذا الفتى هو
أنا!
(تصفيق)
أنا من كان والده مريضًا بسرطان الكبد!
وقد توفي؛ بسبب سرطان الكبد.
والذي كانت والدته تكافح كل يوم لمعالجته.
حسنًا، أتتذكرون الخطوة...
(تصفيق)
كما قلت لكم
هؤلاء مجرد إرشادات أو أدوات قمت باتباعهم.
وغير ملزم عليك باتباعهم
عليك بأن تدرك ذاتك!
ستتمكن من السيطرة على المشاعر،
والتعامل بكل سلاسة مع الخسارة.
أتتذكرون الخطوة المتعلقة بأن تكون مبدعًا؟
لقد كتبت شعرًا، وأود مشاركته معكم!
(هتاف)
“كلما حاولت التخلي عنه”
“كان دائمًا عالقًا هناك”
“كان شعورًا بالاضطراب”
“شعور لم أتمكن من التخلي عنه”
“لا يمكنني التخلي عنك!”
“لأنك نوري!”
“وجودك هنا لا يزال يلمع مشرقًا”
“لا زالت أشعر بكل تحركاتك”
“لكن في النهاية، بلا أي تحسن”
“ربما خسارتك لم تكن بهذا السوء”
“لكن لماذا تتركني هنا حزينًا؟”
“هل يمكنك سماعي؟”
“أيمكنك سماع دعائي؟”
“أم أنه صراخ عبثًا يطفو في الهواء؟”
“لقد حاولت تقبل التغيير، لكنه صعب للغاية.”
“لما لم تتمكن من المكوث معنا؟”
“عليَّ تعلم كيف لي أن أتقبل”
“استرخ الآن يا عزيزي. فقد حصلت عليه”
“الجميع يخطئ، لكن عليك والاعتراف”
“فمعركتك كانت الأكثر دموية”
“فهي مكافحة المجهول وثقال الأمور”
“تلمع عيناي؛ على علمٍ من أنك تراقبني أنمو”
“لقد أحببتك أكثر فأكثر كل يوم متبعًا إرثك”
“أنا لن أتخلى عنك؛ فأنا عائلتك!”
“رغم ذلك، فإنه لا يزال حيًا في ذهني”
“رغم ذلك، فإنه لا يزال يعيش في ذهني”
شكرًا لكم!
(تصفيق)